50% of men aged 18 to 30 say that they
haven't approached a woman in the last
year that's not surprising at all
there's a Pew research study out there
that sort of corroborated of the men
that are not in a relationship it's
something like 53% of them 57% of that
number reported not being able to
approach a woman or being afraid to
approach a woman as the reason why
they're not in a relationship you have a
culture of guys they feel like maybe the
modern world has kind of robbed them of
something in terms of meaning or purpose
or connection that there is an imbalance
and some unfairness going on and they
want to kind of grab life by the horns
and finally get a purpose at the same
time being sedated heavily by video
games social media screens and then when
it comes to the women thing as well a
lot of the time the guys will applaud an
Andrew Tate somebody who really does
Forge their own path when it comes to
women it doesn't slow him down and he'll
go do this thing but then how many of
the 50% of men that haven't approached a
woman in the last year are part of that
cohort I think that the Fallout of an
overly zealous me too movement has been
catastrophic for women's dating desires
completely